i would say that Microsoft has been an
innovative company they've done some
really interesting things most of the
things that they've tried to do that
broke new ground have been horrible
failures the spot watch a wristwatch
that gets your email weather sports
stocks right on your wrist the fact that
it requires a monthly fee for your watch
and it stops working when you leave your
area code and the fact that you have to
recharge it every single night never
became a massive hit the tablet pc I
remember Bill Gates saying at one trade
show that in five years the tablet pc
would be the predominant kind of laptop
sort of innovative in its way never it
found niches health care insurance but
you know no is that is that is it fifty
percent no it's five percent the
wireless screen that was interesting
they for a while they sold just a screen
that communicated with the actual
computer wirelessly died a horrible
death so they do try and they do they do
innovate you can't say they've never
innovated they also do an awful lot of
copying of other people
I think Microsoft has a lot of
disincentive to break its mold at the
moment obviously windows and microsoft
office are microsoft's cash cows they
will stay its cash cows they will remain
the mainstay of corporate america and
until that changes which would be
decades probably microsoft has no real
innovator no real motivation to change
to really break out for example everyone
saying who the next thing is going to be
software on the web so you don't install
it on your computer you use it on the
web like google has Google's own office
programs on the web Microsoft has a huge
disincentive to embrace that because
it's getting hundreds of dollars per
copy of its office and its windows and
so on so Microsoft makes billions of
dollars and would make millions of
billions of dollars if it did nothing at
all but coast so I don't see anything
changing
I do not think you will see in any new
computer companies I think the personal
computer is a commodity it's like buying
a phone its buying a TV it's just it's
not interesting it's not where the hot
developments are it's for most people
about price at this point so I think the
the wave of interestingness and
excitement that moved on from the pc